(slogans des manifestants)
- Coût de la vie qui ne cessed's
insuffisantes pour lutter
contre la crise climatique :
c'est l'argumentaire
de ces milliers de manifestants
qui arpentent les rues de Paris.
- La majorité des gens,
aujourd'hui, si on réduit
à 1500 euros, ils vont payer
500 euros d'escence.
Est-ce que le but d'un travail,
ce n'est pas de gagner
de l'argent, ce n'est pas
de s'enrichir un tant soit peu
pour faire profiter nos enfants
de peut-être... d'activités?
- Il n'y a pas non plus
de choses qui sont faites
pour le climat, pour notre
avenir, et donc nous,
on se demande : Bien,
dans cette société-là,
quelle est notre place?
- Au milieu des drapeaux,
toute la gauche est représentée,
à commencer par l'ex-candidat
à la présidentielle
Jean-Luc Mélenchon, initiateur
de ce re Il est
accompagné de la prix Nobel
de littérature Annie Ernaux.
Les manifestants réclament
entre autres du gouvernement
Macron des gels de prix,
des augmentations de salaire
au-delà de l'inflation
nvestissements à hauteur
de centaines de milliards
d'euros dans la transition
écologique.
- Si t'es pas content, casse-
toi! La relève, elle est là!
(coups de feu)
(cris)
Cette marche survient en pleine
grève dans les raffineries
de Total, qui entraîne
des pénurburant,
et à l'approche d'une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation initiée
par la Confédération générale
du travail prévue mardi.
- Au début, ils nous traitent...
torités craignent
d'ailleurs que le mouvement
de grève ne se propage à
d'autres secteurs de l'économie.
VINCENT TOURAINE,ation spéciales
- Aussi, les centrales
nucléaires dont on commence
à parler, mais aussi
le ferrovière, et là, à partir
du moment où on rèverèverèverève
à la SNCF, qui est la compagnie
nationale, la RLTP, c'est-à-dire
les transports parisiens,
là, on se dit que ça risque
mal, d'autant
qu'un des syndicats qui appelle
à cette journée d'action parle
de grève peut-être reconductibl.
- L'augmentation!
De nos salaires!
- Tout ça alors que le conflit
de travail chez Total paralyse
le pays depuis près de trois
semaines.
Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canada, Mon